ich möchte nun mit meinem aufreger-thema
starken was ich jetzt schon ehrlich
sagen muss wahrscheinlich jetzt für sie
etwas belanglos wirkung wird nach dieser
wichtigen debatte meine thema heute
abend ist trotzdem die these 3g muss für
alle bürger weg wir finden nachts
verfolgt weiß ja wie wenig verständnis
ich für die meisten kroner maßnahmen
habe und mir ist es sehr wichtig dass
wir bei diesem thema auch dranbleiben
als redaktion zweig plus hätten niemals
eingeführt werden dürfen von der
einrichtungs bezogen im pflicht ganz zu
schweigen und während andere länder dem
studium der feiern müssen wir unsere
masken tragen schon lange halte ich
vieles für politischen irrsinn doch
heute dachte ich mir wirklich jetzt in
die deutschen was ist passiert eine
gruppe von rund 50 geflüchteten aus der
ukraine die eigentlich nach paris reisen
wollten konnte am samstag aufgrund einer
streckensperrung nicht weiterreisen und
wollte in ein hotel das war aber nicht
möglich der grund kaum einer aus der
gruppe konnte ein 3g nachweis erbringen
darüber berichtete die stuttgarter
zeitung die flüchtlinge verbrachten die
nacht auf grund des fehlenden nachweis
in einem warteraum der bahn ich frage
mich schon seit längerem was wollen wir
für ein land sein wie lange seine
menschlichkeit und empathie noch von
impfnachweis abhängig sein und hört
unsere solidarität mit den flüchtlingen
auf aufgrund eines 3g nachweises das ist
mein thema heute abend was ich gerne mit
der runde debattieren möchte und ich
würde gerne die frage direkt in hennig
spielen sie haben die geschichte ja
bestimmt gehört was haben sie da
empfunden dass flüchtlinge nicht ins
hotel durfte aufgrund eines 3g
nachweises ja dass nur traurig denn wir
sind dankbar für diese
warme aufnahme von vielen vielen
menschen das sind schon zehntausende die
in deutschland angekommen sind aus der
ukraine
100.000 in polen und es ist erstaunlich
dass das nur weil eben diese formalität
da ist dass die menschen gar keinen
zugang zu einem hostel oder zu einem
hotel haben das kann man nur schwer
verstehen verstehen wenn man bedenkt
dass diese menschen einen weg hinter
sich zurück gelegt haben denn man keinem
so etwas wünschen würde und wenn man
überlegt dass in einen anderen ländern
auch nicht so wäre also nicht nur einer
das war ein kinder und frauen sind ja
weil die männer die bleiben und viele
kinder sind auch allein unterwegs weil
auch mütter die heimat nicht verlassen
konnte und das ist schon krass was da
geschieht herr kuban wie sind sie das
denn mit der deutschen innenpolitik in
zukunft wir haben jetzt bei den
flüchtlingen nicht nur die problematik
mit dem 3g nachweis die impfquote sie
auch wesentlich geringer als in
deutschland in der ukraine wie soll
deutschland da in zukunft vorgehen
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich war
letzte woche auch an der polnisch
ukrainischen grenze viele von den
menschen dort gesehen von gerade den
müttern mit kindern die sich auf den weg
gemacht haben und
ehrlicherweise
bedrückt mich das leid was ich dort
gesehen habe ein bisschen mehr als
unsere im oder 3g regeln der zeitweilig
auch ganz offen und ehrlich sage ich
erwartet dass dort unbürokratische
lösungen gefunden werden aber natürlich
weiß ich auch dass momentan beim ihrer
region hannover mit 1,2 millionen
einwohnern nur irgendwie 120 leute
hospitalisiert sind und man kann über
alle streiten aber wir dürfen jetzt die
themen aus meiner sicht auch nicht
vermischen mir geht es darum dass wir
das leid in der ukraine bekämpfen dass
wir dafür sorgen dass wladimir putin
diesen grausamen krieg beendet und dass
er möglichst nicht mehr länger präsident
der russischen föderation ist das ist
mein ziel aber das andere thema rückt
für mich ziemlich in den hintergrund wir
dürfen die sachen jetzt nicht vermischen
wenn ich jetzt teilweise auch solche
tweets von ralf stegner lese wir müssen
uns jetzt auf die unsere ressourcen auf
den klimawandel beschränkt und dürften
deswegen keinen krieg führen dann ist
das total absurd und läuft und wie alles
in die falsche richtung deswegen finde
ich wir sollten den fokus auf die
ukraine lenken und wie wir helfen können
also ich weiß wir fingen ehrlich gesagt
die worte bei so einem beispiel auch der
botschafter hat gerade gesagt wenn man
48 stunden unterwegs ist vielleicht nur
noch das nötigste am leib trägt was man
überhaupt besessen hat alles
zurückgelassen hat halt sogar weiß dass
das haus oder die wohnung zerstört ist
dann in ein freies land kommt das land
sagt nee du das hier nicht in einem
normalen bett schlafen weil die der test
oder den impfausweis fehlt dann glaube
ich kann man auch den glauben an die
freiheit ganz schnell wieder verlieren
mein eindruck ist überhaupt über die
vergangenen jahre dass wir in
deutschland es sehr gut gelernt haben
uns in einem regel korsett extrem gut zu
bewegen aber in diesem regel korsett zu
bleiben und bloß nicht auszugehen es
heißt haben uns angewöhnt weil viele
dinge einfach nicht gut laufen stichwort
ausrüstung der bundeswehr und dann war
es viel wichtiger in afghanistan
beispielsweise dass die mülltrennung
funktioniert hat in den camps in denen
die bundeswehr war das erzählen ja die
soldaten immer wieder gerne wenn sie
zurückgekommen sind oder die die da
waren dass also die mülltrennung extrem
wichtig waren hat man gesehen wie die
afghanen am ende wenn sie den müll aus
der blauen der braunen der gelben und
der grauen tonne abgeholt haben hinter
dem camp einfach zusammen geschmissen
haben also die mühe war umsonst was sie
nur sagen will ist dieser regel irrsinn
der sich da bei uns in vielerlei
hinsicht manchmal bahn bricht der trifft
jetzt auf eine wirklichkeit und ist
eigentlich beschämend dass menschen die
alles zurückgelassen haben und dem tod
wahrscheinlich ganz knapp entronnen sind
jetzt nicht in einem normalen weichen
bett schlafen können weil sie
möglicherweise ihren impfausweis auf der
flucht verloren haben da fehlen mir die
worte
mir auch und dementsprechend bin ich
trotzdem froh auch wenn herr kuban dass
er als etwas belangloses gerade also
angesichts des leides muss man wirklich
sagen also das was man momentan sieht
was wir heute wieder für bilder gesehen
haben was wir dort vor ort sehen daher
warte ich einfach dass es eine
unbürokratische lösung gibt und das hat
für mich jetzt auch weniger mit regel
ihr sind zu tun muss ich auch ganz offen
und ehrlich gestehen sondern glaube dass
es da wesentliche probleme gibt die wir
lösen müssen und vor ort dann einfach
auch mal ein bisschen mit einem auge das
ganze als der menschenverstand wartet